well holy smoke is this ain't no jokers
welcome into the iced coffee hour i
believe
this is episode 21 and you gentlemen
have made 6 200
so far we have an epic episode for you
guys okay we're gonna talk about
stocks we're gonna talk about investing
we're gonna talk about stocks i like
right now
i'm gonna break some news in this video
that is earth shattering okay it's
actually not news about me
it's news about this guy right here okay
this is
massive news and when i say massive i'm
talking about gargantuan
i'm talking about as big as a massive
state okay
think about a massive state like
california that's what we're going to
get into
this is going to be a big podcast we are
going to beat kevin's view count
in this video we're taking them down
kevin your dust
let's get into this wow watch till the
end
and enjoy oh also you're our first ever
recurring guest
congratulations thanks congratulations
welcome
so with that said enjoy the episode
enjoy
thank you for coming on jeremy
absolutely thanks for having me again
guys
the last episode was amazing man so well
yeah
until kevin came on your episode was the
number one
most viewed episode ever wow on the
podcast because i think we were talking
about investing how beginners could
invest our best investment strategies
how to make a lot of money
and your business and people don't
realize just
how successful everything you're doing
is
and just the possibilities out there are
insane like i'm learning a lot from just
these podcasts
listening to you talk oh i appreciate it
i'm just mad that kevin beat me in views
i guess
i like that just disappoints me now my
day's ruined i don't know if i could
focus on this podcast
what do we have to do now what do we
have that's why jeremy came back on
jeremy came back on just so we can get
more views than kevin and then we're
going to have kevin come back on
and then what we're going to do is have
you and kevin
and then we just break the platform
it'll only be kevin and jeremy we're not
even going to be in it just them
exactly then we just break the platform
just you just shut down the next thing
you can't handle that oh gosh thank you
for this iced coffee today graham by the
way i didn't come with starbucks today
so i appreciate this like last time oh
of course
make sure to smash the like button for
that it's always some good news
and for those of you who do not know
jeremy has two
youtube channels and he talks mainly
about stock investing
more so long-term strategies than
short-term strategies
and yeah i mean what else is there to
yeah so in your public account so you
have a public account where you
basically show
the stocks you're investing and anybody
could see it that's almost up to a
million dollars right
it's cruising yeah a lot of people think
it's gonna hit a million this year i'm
i'm a little worried
yeah i don't know man because tesla
might kind of like start just kind of
chilling for a while
and that's the biggest position in that
account so but yeah i'm super thrilled
with it it's been it's been a
hell of a past couple years i can tell
you that what did you start off with in
that account
that account started from zero i started
adding money in we just you know
started building building building um i
got in a lot of good deals in
like november december of 2018.
the market had a big dip in q4 that year
that i started building out
you know tesla heavier sky work
solutions facebook
started building those positions and um
and then we just kept rolling into 2019
i got some hot stocks like elf
this year it's been uh like fizzy get
dizzy
national beverage corporation you know
we have nicknames for them all
um and and planet 13 and a few others
and uh
so that account we've just been we've
been roaring the only really bad stock
we've had unfortunately was the ccl
which unfortunately you know with a once
in a hundred year event man sometimes
you you got one of those bats i bought
in
carnival at like 11 well done it was
like 10 or 11 or it was like 9 10 or 11.
and i remember thinking i put like i
think it was like 10 grand maybe it was
10 15
000. here's just a bet if i'm wrong and
wrong
if i'm right then hey i'll make some
money off of this but i put in it at one
of the worst times and i think what is
it that no 17
yeah i think well maybe 16 i don't know
the specific price but yeah
and cheesecake factory you got me on it
by the way graham got me on a cheesecake
factory and i've made
you know like i think 40 on that stock
yeah thank you i
yeah i got a cheesecake factory i think
it what price was i telling you at it
was under 20. i think it was like 18.
yeah so i bought in i bought in just a
big chunk i think 30 or 40 000
at 18 and then when i saw it hit 30 i
was like what
but you know what the reason i i started
to notice this when i invest in
companies that i use myself they always
do well
cheesecake factory was one of those when
i was telling you about this i would go
and get the cheesecake factory
for takeout and the line was crazy this
is like the worst
of the worst like at the peak at the
shutdown everything the line for
cheesecake like you would have to order
an hour in advance
yeah i'm thinking i can't be the only
one cheesecake factory is good food
good prices so i'm gonna put my money
where my mouth is
and that paid for all the cheesecake
factory of a lifetime yeah
i just like to do it that's the way to
do it right basically every tesla owner
that i know as soon as they got a tesla
they started buying tesla shares yeah
because they saw how good the product
itself was which i think is a pretty
good strategy you employ that strategy
as well right yeah
yeah i mean i i i buy into companies all
the time that i actually use the
products
and like the cheesecake factory we go
back to that one i did the same thing i
would go to the cheesecake factory it
was busy
i would check out like north italia
another chain that they own
that was busy and i'm like um i was
right there with you and i saw the
financing they did they got they raised
like i think it was 200 mil
in april and i was like they're going to
get through this fine and and sure
enough you know here we are and you know
incredible gains but thank you for uh
yeah for for putting me down
absolutely uh another few uh docusign
was a great one
yeah dropbox dropbox is how often come
is
it yes that's an up and comer that's
going to be 2021 through
i think 2025. it's going to go on use
that all the time
uh rocket mortgage it's not that people
are talking about that one yeah
so i i invested in rocket mortgage
recently
okay and uh i could see it because loan
demand right now is just crazy
yeah and especially rocket mortgage i'm
seeing so i have the mentorship group
linked down below in the description uh
but lately people are comparing the
rates they're getting
rocket mortgage has consistently been
the best rates for people
consistently and this is this is not
just like one person the group it seems
like
multiple people now are like i went off
the other person's recommendation i went
through rocket mortgage they are gonna
be this crazy deal
so i i think and it usually will take a
few months for this to start showing up
but i think we give it a few months
yeah rocket mortgage is gonna be great
yeah i mean i've done a lot of thinking
on that one
the valuation's a bit high but so the
one part of me is i think they are
killing it right now and i think they're
going to continue to kill it for like at
least the next year because everybody's
refinancing like crazy yeah including
uh we just refinanced on our house um
recently because we got down to like 2.7
or 2.8 percent
and so uh from whatever we were at 3.6
or whatever
and so i'm looking at that one but what
i'm worried about is i'm worried about
when everybody gets done refinancing
what does that look like for them
so that's kind of what i'm trying to
judge because you have you're paying a
a hefty premium for the company that's
valuation-wise
and then it's like how long does this
insane demand they're gonna have for the
next six to twelve months how does it
keep up for two years three years
or are they good forever with the with
the super high demand that's true
how is rocket mortgage able to offer
such low
interest rates on their loans is it just
because i'm guessing they don't have
like a brick and mortar
right it's a low overhead it's an
interesting stock ticker symbol rkt
okay yeah yep exactly what do you think
of the study that
easy to pronounce ticker symbols tend to
do better
yeah i don't know about that i haven't
seen the studies specifically there was
a study that analyzed 30 to 40 years of
returns you found
that easy to remember and easy to spell
ticker symbols like
cake for instance tend to outperform the
broader market
wow consistently yeah and we could take
one step further what about companies
that the name of the company is the same
as a ticker such as zoom
because zoom is zoom like the ticker
symbol is the same as the company zoom
zoom
z-o-o-m uh that's interesting but then
you also have
zm
everybody's thought that was zoom stock
and they were invested in body crazy oh
gosh and the stock
went up like more than actual zoom stock
went up people got so lucky
and there was another one uh ford
f-o-r-d
is not forward yeah it's just stuff
right so people were buying
ford uh in anticipation of the bronco
coming out instead of just
so ford saw a blip having nothing to do
with this there's been a few of them
what was the other oh
fang did you hear about this
there was this okay so it came out it
came out that like fang stocks are doing
this crazy thing
but fang stuffs are up like 80 90 so far
and
there's a company called uh bang
f-a-a-n-g
and people were buying into that it went
up like 200 percent
in a few days wow just out of a mistake
yeah that's right yes you see it being
like a few dollars and it shoots up to
14
and then back down a few days later when
people realize the mistake
the real thing for you those you
facebook apple netflix google it's like
an acronym that's used out there in the
stock market space a lot that's
ridiculous yeah
that whole story yeah jeez it's funny do
you guys know how companies lock in
different ticker symbols
um i mean you just have to go through
the process as long as it's available
usually you can get it approved as long
as
usually it's uh four letters or less
so yeah as long as nobody else has it
you can pretty much claim it on whatever
you know indices you go public on
have you thought about starting an etf
i've noticed kevin o'leary had an etf
fund
that's tempting oh shares yeah we call
them we're looking into it it's a
possibility
um it would be interesting we're just
we're just it's something we're looking
into but i don't know if we'll actually
do it
because i'm still not 100 sure on like
you know what all the legal requirements
are
around that and and um you know if you
have something like that can you come
out
publicly say i'm buying such and such
stock if you have your own etf
um i don't know it's it's something
we're exploring it's going to take a
while though yeah
how would he make money with that i
don't know i don't know that's it
maybe it's a management fee i think
that's an expense ratio
i think there's some sort of management
fee you get off that but i'm not 100
sure so it's something we'll look into
next year and try to see if
yeah i think a lot of people would be
interested if i did come out with
something like that
of course because your gains are crazy
too right yeah
what's your average roi since you
started the public account
public account so well last year i know
for sure we got a 91
return uh by fidelity but a lot of that
was tesla
i'm gonna be the critic 100 yeah yeah
yeah
91 last year one year rate of return
we're at right now for the public i
think it's 151 percent calculated by
fidelity
um but yeah like tesla's been a beast
um but almost all of our stocks have
been really good it's just tesla's that
like insane performer
tesla's the one that's gone up i think
we're up eight hundred percent now in
tesla
what would you say the return would be
without tesla without testing that's
been one of the biggest critiques yeah
that i've seen so far
is that portfolio is led by tesla for
tesla
yeah i would say probably more to like
40 to 50 percent
okay because maybe a little higher than
that uh one year rate of return we're
talking i think
maybe even up to maybe 60 because
although tesla's up massively
it was already going up a lot um into
this past
year and then tesla represents about
300k of that portfolio
out of about 800 something thousand so
i don't know we'd have to do the math on
it it probably wouldn't be i would say
forty percent to sixty percent one year
rate of return got it if i didn't even
own it tesla got it so
um yeah so i mean i'm thrilled about it
but yeah you know it's all about like
one stock can can pretty much almost
change your life i mean i i've seen it
with
countless people the amount of people we
have like in the six and seven figure
club
that got carried there because the tesla
stock is rooted yeah
i remember um uh one guy i met
a while ago amd i think he was in your
group
yeah probably yeah yeah yeah yeah when
amc
yeah he was in your group and he put
like what two hundred thousand dollars
into amd
remember that like but it was 15
yeah and sold it at like 60. the crazy
thing is
if you go back five years ago amd was
like two three dollars a share
and now it's i think like 70. yeah
something like that
imagine you load up you believe in it so
much at two three dollars
and you're like this company's got to
come on a great comeback they got a new
ceo
and uh oh gosh but the thing is like if
it goes from two to four
you know a lot of people are gonna sell
yes you know like i just doubled up my
money i'm getting out of this
you know but uh respect to the people
that have held yeah it makes me wonder
too
how many people have held bitcoin since
it was worth like a dollar
50 cents until now yeah because a lot of
people say oh i
i had 200 bitcoin back and they didn't
but yet
that's a good point a lot of people
would sell as soon as it doubles
from you know a dollar to 30 you're like
oh
better sell this every time i release a
tesla video there's always like that one
or two comments of somebody saying
you know tesla went up initially like 30
40 and they sold out and they was the
biggest regret of their lives or their
financial lives
it happens all the time man because it's
just like you you see
you know with stocks that's the thing is
difficult you log into your account you
go on your phone
you're like i just made 30 in two weeks
on the stock or three months
and you're like this is ridiculous the
next thing you know you're just feeling
all emotional and you're like
i gotta lock in my profits let me let's
just sell how often do you sell
shares in your accounts very rarely yeah
it's very rare um
i mean the only reasons for me to really
sell is if i'm getting
too over diversified where it's too many
positions and i'm not getting my
account focused it's just like i'm all
over the place or
if the company fundamentals change for
the worse
i don't even usually sell even if i feel
a company is
super highly valued for instance tesla i
still hold tesla in the public account
every single share of all those
you know well it was originally 150 then
they split so now i think it's like 750
shares
but it's gone up so much and i'm still
not selling even though i feel like
tesla stock is
is very expensive i'm not selling tesla
just because
like like why why would i sell it just
because it's highly priced that's all
relative right
you know we're filming this in santa
monica and we could say well that house
is
highly priced it's well somebody might
pay that price
so um so yeah it's it's pretty rare that
i'll i'll sell positions
nowadays i'm just like like facebook
skywars i'm still holding every share i
bought
in those when i was buying back in 2018
in that account
i think i got 371 facebook shares in
that account
and i can't remember how many sky works
but yeah it's just not it's not worth
getting rid of great assets whether it's
stocks real estate in my opinion that
are long-term investments years it's
just like
why would you what am i going to do put
in cash
cash is you know getting devalued every
day how many stocks do you like to have
at a given point
uh so public account i have 15 stocks
and that's about what i'm comfortable
that when it goes over a million i
might take it up to 20 but i really want
to keep it under 20 because
you get to a point where you just get
too over diversified and you got to you
got to keep in mind you want to be
diversified but you want to have your
money in the best positions possible
and so you know we have it sometimes
where somebody will join the private
group and like we do like
portfolio reviews where they can send me
their portfolio sometimes these people
will send me their portfolio dude
and they'll have like you know uh 35 000
in their account and they got 35 stocks
and it's like a thousand a piece and
it's like you're all over the place man
you should if you're going to be
at that point you might just buy an
index fund if you want to be an
individual stock picker
you need to be in your best positions
you know those those
you know especially with that small
amount of money you might want to be in
your five or ten biggest positions
uh your best positions that you love the
most that's where you're going to get
the gains that seems like the opposite
of the
kevin o'leary approach yeah probably
five percent so so if you have a hundred
thousand dollars you should do five
thousand dollars per yeah and pick 20
different stocks
i think though in a situation where you
have much less money like 35 000
or 100 000 there's only a certain
threshold that you kind of need to
surpass
like you said yeah if you had 1 million
you'd have 20 positions
but if you had like 50 million you'd
probably have like quite a bit more
because then you start changing your
priorities to capital presence
yeah exactly what once you get a ton of
money yeah it's about not just growing
your money but keeping the money as well
100
but i mean when you're on the come up
you know it's
like i haven't known anybody in in my
life you know personally
who um got truly rich right
without being um super into one thing
whether that was their business
or a couple real estate properties and
it got them there or a few
stocks that made them you know super
successful um
you know so it's it's hard to be you
know have your money all over the place
a lot of times the game changer for you
is is having your money in the five to
ten
best things you got going for you in my
in my personal opinion
so how do you pick stocks let's say i'm
a
gosh that's yeah let's go through the
process jeremy
six hours later yeah we're in part two
at that point
oh gosh i mean the the biggest thing at
the end of the day
like people always ask me like what's
the biggest thing it's it's the
fundamentals of the business
it's by far like you can look at all the
metrics return on invested capital
uh return on equity price sales ratio
forward ps trailing fees you can look at
all these things prices sales you know
you can look at so many different
factors but i can tell you it's always
the business fundamentals all right but
let me start here
what website do you go to first uh well
it depends on what you're looking for i
mean yeah you know yahoo finance is
still
you know although it's gotten
progressively worse over the years yeah
we find it's still pretty decent okay um
for like getting basic information about
a company
so let's say you want to look into apple
stock you know you can type in apple
there
get their their metrics and things like
that but of course if you're new to the
market you aren't even going to know
what the metrics are right
so but i mean the great thing nowadays
is you have google
so like let's say you hear me say ford p
ratio and you're like a four p e ratio
what is that
like like i don't think people quite get
this like literally you can google on
your phone what is a forward p e ratio
and it will be
explained you exactly down to detail
from like investopedia right on google
um we're gonna get comments right now
what's a forward p e ratio what is that
a four p is basically looking at the
next 12 months of earnings versus where
that stock price is at right now
it's one of the most important metrics i
personally look at because
as a as a forward-looking investor i
want to focus on where this company's
going over the next year but also a few
you know several years out and uh yeah i
mean the
you know to get back like the business
fundamentals so important like people
way overlook that all the time they want
to get caught up into the
the metrics and all this companies cheap
and things like that it's like if you
can find a great company that has
a decade of growth in front of them more
than likely you're going to make an
insane amount of money
it's just as as simple as that basically
um you know amazon
i i looked into amazon my first time i
think was 2010 right
i love the business model loved it i was
like this is brilliant
i looked at the valuation i thought
that's too expensive amazon was like 50
to 100
a share back then it's like what three
thousand dollars now
that was stupid you know what i mean i
should i should have been buying as many
amazon shares as possible
because i understood this business model
is a game changer so although it might
look expensive
put the money in man put the money in so
it all comes back to
the ceo and the business fundamentals
and where that company's going and
competitive advantages they have in the
market
what are the biggest red flags you see
when you're evaluating a stock you come
across something you're like oh no this
is a deal breaker
uh really bad balance sheet what does
that mean so
you know balance sheet is essentially
the financial health of a company
you know you think about your own your
own self and your own life right you
have
you have your own balance sheet you have
a certain amount of assets and
liabilities
uh debts things like that and you know
obviously if you have too many debts
that's a bad thing especially if they're
bad debts
and i think balance sheet shows like the
competence of the management team
i think is big you know if if a balance
sheet is really
bad let's say for instance and they're
loaded up with debt they have hardly any
cash it just means it's a mismanaged
business and like what the heck are they
doing
more than likely so the balance sheet is
honestly one of the biggest
keys like that's going to drive the
whole business because if you don't have
the money around in a business how do
you
how do you invest in the business do you
look for cash
on a balance sheet i'm looking for cash
and investments and i'm also looking at
what are the debts
uh short-term debts long-term debts i'm
not really looking at their rent
related debts because they started um
accounting for that on balance sheets
over the past year or two and i think
that's
kind of a mistake in my opinion um like
long-term lease liabilities
but i'm looking for all the other debts
essentially so
yeah that's really big um you know
that's one of the that's one of the red
flags another red flag is if the ceo
buys a yacht like the gopro ceo did
[Laughter]
no i mean sometimes these management
teams you know um
you know they'll get really rich you
know obviously you take a company public
you get really rich and then you you
maybe get a little uh
unfocused so i think if you see a
management team that
is focusing their attentions on more
leisure activities than
business was that was that a disc
towards trevor milton
that was bought with 35 million dollar
ranch exactly
what do you think of that that that
you've been taking down trevor milton
oh uh nicola yeah oh yeah
yeah no allegedly because i don't want
to get
these videos taken down allegedly they
have now been removing videos
that show um their truck
going downhill allegedly
wow a few channels have uh complained
about that
yeah the red flags for nikola were there
that's why a lot of us were calling it
out and people were like oh or you guys
just you guys are you know
because i'm talking about the whole like
almost everybody in the tesla community
myself and a lot of the other most
important like youtubers in the tesla
community we're
all calling that out because it was so
sketch man like the whole situation was
so sketchy you wanna talk about red
flags it was just loaded with red flags
i thought nicola was almost like a joke
company because it was like nikola tesla
yeah it's just
it seemed like it seemed like it's just
a bad copycat
of that yeah but it goes to show you
that to me was like the most elaborate
i don't want to call it like a like a
hoax yeah i don't want to call it a hoax
but
it was one of the most elaborate plants
yeah that i've seen in a long time
i mean this guy made how much money
partner he got a partnership with gm
yeah who's now i guess looking into
they're reevaluating that yeah
we'll see yeah we'll see how it all
turns out but yeah i mean you know that
was just
uh a massive risk that honestly you know
has paid off really poorly for most
investors you know
i mean at peak i think it was at 90
dollars uh
you know nicola so yeah i mean the the
thing is
you know if we draw it back to like why
are people even getting involved with
nicholas talk why they go up so much
everybody wants the next tesla
everybody wants the next tesla man and
they're so desperate for it
so desperate for it so what do you think
has the potential to be the next tesla
uh well there are few companies out
there i think
i mean the stock i'm most excited about
if we're thinking about growth over the
next
10 years i would say probably plant 13
it's a risk like
yeah it's a risk like tesla was back in
the day
you know you're going to say that yeah
it is it's just there's nothing i can
find better than that
um for for the reward potential now i
can find more attractive risk rewards
than plant 13 out there meaning you're
balancing what are the chances you lose
money in that stock over the next five
years versus you make you know a double
up triple up quadruple up with your
money
but yeah i can't really find any i've
looked you know
at you know i look at stocks all day
pretty much and i can't find anything
that
has that type of growth potential um
because you're talking about a company
that basically has one massive store
they got a store opening up in santa ana
in 2021
they had their other little store in
vegas opening back up which was making
like five mil a quarter
like that's just a little store um and
their brand's expansion it's just like
if they if they execute man that's
that's gonna be a multi-billion dollar
company
what about snowflake snowflakes got such
a rich valuation on now i mean it's
incredibly you know i mean in the in the
spectrum of like
the richest valuations you can find or
like the cheapest companies you can find
snowflake is literally at the end of the
richest companies you can find in terms
of valuation being insane
it doesn't mean they can't fulfill that
over time but
yeah i mean the valuation has gotten
pushed up so much because everybody's
desperate
to get in the next sales force or
another one was game
that's what it seems like for me
everyone just wants to get in like
what's the next quick like money maker
thing and they're
all it's like this big hive yes a bees
it's just like oh let's go right here
into that and they pump it up and then
it's like oh what's that over there
yeah they blow it up yes and that's what
it seems like these little spots of just
but if you time it you time it right and
that's what i think everyone's thinking
yeah everyone has the same mentality
like if i just time this right
everyone's gonna
bump it up and then i sell two days
later i think that's what happened to
snowflake everyone thought that they
were gonna get in early
ride it for a day or two and then drop
it but
all of that momentum in the beginning
just shot it up and it did nothing but
go down
yeah 100 we were you know and it's even
worse in like the vc space we were we
were chatting you know blake and i on
like the ride over here from vegas
yesterday and
we were talking about he's like would
you ever do like a vc fund or something
like that and i was like
if it got way less competitive maybe but
in a vc space like if you think what's
going on the public markets is bad
like look to the venture capital space
man because those guys are so desperate
for the next facebook or the next chime
or whatever it is
they will push valuations up to whatever
they need to just to try to get into the
next
maybe big thing like it doesn't matter
almost what you launch as long as it's
some sort of idea and it's growing it
doesn't have to be
even a business model that makes sense
for the most part as long as you're
growing users somehow
like these vc guys are desperate to put
money it would be so much fun to try our
own hosting of shark tank
just do our own thing could you imagine
that we could try it whoa
seriously and just and get people who
just don't you know don't have the other
resources
uh of getting themselves just i'm
talking like
i don't want to say kids but like young
adults who don't know where to turn
they watch youtube videos they're like i
have this concept or this this thing i'm
working on i just don't have the capital
for it because i'm stuck in a full-time
job but if i leave that drop i can't pay
my rent
but i need like 30 grand to get this off
off the ground and to support myself for
a year
that would do so well i like that like
maybe we should do that we need to do it
like a youtube edition
yeah yeah but the thing is we don't want
to copy shark tank like verbatim because
then it's like all right just
copying but but have a cool spin on
things get like three of us four of us
together
and just the the maximum would be like
50 grand well and you're you're friends
with kevin o'leary now so we can get him
on the show
oh jesus yeah
um you know what we might have to just
turn these off and on you guys are both
white i know what are the chances man
but uh i think that would be fun if you
guys like that idea
just uh let us know down below in the
description i'll make that happen
uh i think that would be a fun concept
have the platform i'm sure there are
people with good ideas jack you could
screen through these and make sure they
have like a legitimate business
how much money they need just get the
basics you know what it would be it
would be like taking the phone calls on
the second channel
except in person and they're pitching an
idea
that would be cool but we have to the
hardest thing to execute on a plan like
that is we're going to have to come out
with a more epic music
than shark tank
yeah how can you beat that music that's
difficult man
we can have a funny spin on things i
don't know yeah we do we'd have to make
it different enough
if if that's a concept you think is
actually worthwhile i would do that
okay like just fun we would allocate
like 200 grand and do and do whatever it
is and just be like
we're going to give away 200 000 or like
invest 200 000 in certain people
that's actually a concept i wanted to do
for a long time
was being able to invest in a person and
i got i actually got this so
so what my plan was this was like 10
years ago i wanted
to be able to do something where like i
like a specific person and i could be
like i'm going to give you a hundred
grand
and in return for that i'll get like 10
percent of how much money you make for
the next like 20 years yeah
something like that whatever it is
however much but uh
it's so difficult to actually implement
that because they can have write-offs
and expenses and they buy
like certain stuff to get their income
down and i thought that would be really
interesting
and then i got an offer this may have
been two years ago i'm not sure if you
showed me this jack
the the guy who wanted to invest in me
he offered me what was a few hundred
thousand dollars in exchange for like a
portion of how much money
i'm gonna make in any venture i don't
remember that yeah
this was like two years ago what
percentage was i don't know i'm sure i
could find it
um that was me that did that yeah i
don't know if you guys want to talk for
a second i'm sure i could
i'm sure i could find it it's it's so
what percentage of your public account
is principal or how much is principal
i would say probably 300
ish maybe a little over 300 of the 800
and
whatever it's at 60 um is probably money
i put in
because we're we're profiting you know
like let's say i sold all the positions
i have in there right now
were it would be 400 and
i think 50k or somewhere around there
roughly of profits i could take today
that's just pure profit never mind what
i've taken over the past few years
um which i took a good amount of profits
in elf cosmetics i took a good amount of
profits
in cruisey doozy and i took a few other
uh profits so
yeah i mean you we've definitely put in
a good amount to build out those
positions and
like my whole investing strategy is like
putting yourself
before you can actually get to investing
always have yourself in a position where
you can put money in your accounts
one to two times a month so you're
always able to take advantage of dips in
the market
so you've got 300 grand about in
principle in your public account
something like that yeah maybe a little
over 300 but yeah somewhere around there
and do you still ever contribute
to the principle yeah i try to once a
month if not twice a month
every month um you know i try to run
that like i run
any stock account essentially where you
i'm i'm in a position where
at least once twice if possible three
times a month you know contribute some
sort of money and just keep building and
building and building so
and what do you have in store for when
you hit a million nothing
absolutely nothing you're not going to
do it come on yeah the celebration
dude that's good promotion do you have
any celebrations when you hit milestones
like that like net worth milestones
you used to i used to yeah i mean what
did you do when you hit a million let's
talk about that
no no hundred thousand five hundred
thousand a million what did you do
so uh actually ten thousand dollars i
remember i took
my whole immediate family out to dinner
they didn't know what it was for by the
way but i
i knew i had hit ten thousand dollars
net worth um
100 000 i think i took um
i can't remember but i know i took us
all out chipotle
yeah no and i know i took this all out
uh when i hit 100k too
i didn't even do anything when i hit a
million are you serious i didn't do
anything no
yeah i'm kind of disappointed i don't
know did you just like i don't think you
did
you did i've talked about it before
what'd you do yeah
i don't think i know the story either
yeah really not i've mentioned it
multiple times
um so what i did when i hit the million
it was i think it was on like it
came on a perfect day like it was like a
friday thursday friday saturday one of
those nights
and i had a few friends and we got
together for happy hour sushi
didn't i i was the same way i didn't
tell anybody what it was for but i'm
like let's grab sushi tonight
that was it so i got happy hour sushi i
think i may have gotten like a happy
hour beer
or something maybe i don't i don't know
but that's what i did
nice yeah i i do believe in like taking
people out for
when you hit milestones and things like
that but um yeah man
i i didn't do anything when i hit a
million but you you were at ten thousand
dollars
net worth is when you you took your
family out to dinner yeah i might even
have done it at a thousand to be honest
like we might have been a very
affordable dinner like 60 bucks you know
maybe we all went for pizza and wings or
something like that when you hit a
hundred dollar
no could you imagine that you spent it
all and then you actually were down
afterwards yeah i would imagine if you
spent like a hundred dollars on that
dinner with your family at ten thousand
dollars
you could have very well dipped below
the ten thousand dollars yeah
that's true and then you have to
celebrate again the next time you hit
that thank you
okay guys i had a special delivery come
in just for graham's podcast
i didn't have time to stop there's so
much and yeah
right uh yeah postmates ubereats or what
postmates how much was that how much
does that cost
postmates delivery or plus a postmates
charge so we're probably looking at ten
fourteen dollars geez well you gotta tip
on top of that with tax
that's stupid though that's a twenty
dollar do you know what that is
unprofessional
that's fu money that's when you have so
much money hey look at these guys they
use 20
bills as coasters okay who who are they
fake it's fake it's got some
some writing right there i know but uh
twenty dollars
for a drink i didn't pay for it blake
paid for thanks blake gosh
that is f you might think that doesn't
have a scarcity mentality okay let's
talk about scarcity mentality
okay that's too deep of a subject we
don't have i like that mentality you
like
i like i don't like the mentality but i
i i appreciate discussions about it yeah
definitely okay yeah i mean it's because
scarcity mentality is interesting i mean
i can understand you know and i had
scarcity mentality i would say
until about i want to say until about
2013.
yeah i really did um
why why did you have scarcity well so i
mean
when i grew up you know especially in my
younger years we grew up in a rough area
you know like on on food stamps things
like that so right off the bat i was
kind of like in the
like mindset of like you know you got to
try to get everything you can
and try to save everything possible also
i just started saving at a young age i
was always really good at saving
um so it wasn't like i went out and
bought myself stuff all the time i had a
little safe as a kid
um you know even in like middle school
this little safety open with the key and
i keep like 500 bucks or whatever i had
saved in there
and so i always kind of thought in that
way and then i never knew how to make a
lot of money
so it was like i have a limited earning
potential
and i'm a natural saver so it kind of
leads you to more like a scarcity
mentality
i think what kind of got me out of it is
when i started having like exponential
growth in the stock market so like 2012
2013 in the 2014 and i think that
started to lead me out of it
and then when i began my entrepreneurial
journey as
uh you know with the real estate
marketing company that's when i really
got out of scarcity mentality because i
was like oh i can make money for myself
i can start businesses and then i just
totally got out of that
so i still like to this day i saved the
majority of my income
so i i spend a lot too don't get me
wrong but i still save the
majority but i have zero really like
scarcity mentality nowadays
um around like earning potential and
things like that like you know
like now i'm super confident like if you
said you know youtube went away
everything went away i'd be like i'll
just start another like million dollar
business i would just
you know it's just like it's it's
nothing now once you know how to make a
lot of money
it's just so much easier to make a lot
of money because you understand how
teams are built you understand how to
build people together um
you you have all these like resources
and so like as long as you have the
knowledge in your brain you can just go
it's no different than imagine you go to
the gym all the time and like
you get yourself to a place where you
can like bench press let's say 300
pounds or whatever right
even if you were to not work out for a
long time you're still gonna be able to
bench likely
a lot more than the average person it's
just like you're just like you know you
know how to do it
and once you get in the gym again you
start working out that muscle memory is
going to come back because you just like
your body knows how to do it and the
same thing with your mind but your mind
i think it's even more powerful
so like like you you know if you if you
know let's say everything went away
you would be able to start something i i
guarantee you and you'd be highly
successful again
i wouldn't want to do that i believe
start over who does
that's the thing i feel like i've worked
hard enough where i just
why risk it why risk it if i could cut
back on
if i save probably save eight dollars no
actually i would save the inside because
i wouldn't even do that yeah so right
off the bat i'd save an extra 15
i remember working like two hours making
working a whole hour making fifteen
dollars
yup so this to me is like an hour's
worth would i rather have
this for pretty much free or an hour's
worth of my time to buy that
yeah i could i could definitely
understand that yeah there are certain
things now where i feel like
it does make sense to try to buy your
time back
um so there are aspects of that um that
i do feel are worthwhile like i had jack
drive me one time
so i could edit in the car uh so that to
me was a worthwhile
uh expense because now that meant i can
get an extra two hours of work in
um where my time was really well spent
yeah so certain things like that i think
are worth it but this to me seems more
like
an extravagance extra like i wouldn't
get the coffee
you already have a coffee but my life
wouldn't be that much better having this
i would say my life would actually be
worse
because i just don't like those oh okay
see my my quality of life would diminish
my biggest weakness is food and drink if
you if you
look at me that's my best weekend no i
agree okay
me too yeah yeah that's that's my
biggest weakness man i don't i don't
uh i spend a little money on clothes but
the only reason i spend money on clothes
is simply for videos
i i believe me i don't need that that's
that's this is from again
let me guess let me guess something it's
uh it's not it's not
oh no 80. no no
no no it's uh you wear it all the time
what's that one brand you wear all the
time
kenzo kenzo yeah kenzo yeah the ovo
hoodie is probably about 150
200 but you could resell this yeah if it
was new and still wrapped for probably
300 today
because they go fast can i touch it
yeah and this is holographic you
probably can't see it because the lights
i noticed it
okay okay so yeah but i i don't care
about clothes at all like if you see me
like a normal life
uh not in video life uh i wear like
basic five dollar t-shirts
but people love like interesting looks
and things like that so i'll wear like
the the ovo shirts and just like
different stuff that i think is cool for
videos because you make videos every day
and
and sometimes it gets boring man like if
you just wear a plain shirt i don't know
maybe people don't care
some people care some people don't i
find people like the plain shirts i
i just like things without logos on them
for the most part that's smart yeah
don't give them any branding time no i i
like that exactly i like that
so how much better did that sip just
make your life oh my gosh
it's taste is so sweet and beautiful so
sweet and beautiful
it tastes like a ten dollar bill if you
could drink
cheese did we talk about this the last
time how much money you spent
a month i think we did yeah but i don't
know how much so
you don't know i don't know how much
yeah i don't know how much we try to
figure this out
look do you ever look at your credit
card statements and just see where did
my money go
you ever look at the end of the month
and be like this is how much i spent
yeah
i mean well no i don't actually you
don't no
oh yeah you just have automatic payments
on well
my wife handles all that so yeah she
handles that she just sent me a text
today she's like
we just spent two thousand dollars on
blah blah blah today and i'm like wait
what do you mean you spent two days blah
blah blah yeah
yeah well like facebook ads she's like
we spent two thousand dollars just today
on facebook ads
she said something like personal
expenses yeah personal expenses um
i mean personal expenses i would say
10 to 15k uh
as of next year is probably going to go
up to 25 to 30.
okay but what what do those expenses
consist of consist of so right now
uh mortgage on the main henderson house
we have the arizona house which is going
to be finished getting built
in november actually so next month
looking forward to that that will be a
mortgage of
probably i would guess like uh maybe
like 2
500. it's not bad yeah something like
that
um the model x is a thousand a month uh
the model three
is i think 800 a month i want to say
yeah the 700 800 okay um
and then you know various other expenses
food
health care i have kids so obviously the
health care is even more um
and so yeah different things i mean most
of my money spent on business related
things like
um business payroll is probably
50 000 every two weeks i would say wow
100 000 a month um
probably 30 yeah 30 30 like uh
most indirect so most independent
contractors
um so they've gained a commission or
they pay some are paid commissions some
are paid hourly some are paid
weekly it depends uh my coaches
um we have like seven figure coaches in
there right
because we have like coaching packages
in the private group you know those guys
are all multi-millionaires so
you know and they work very high up at
very you know popular tech companies um
and so they're very very expensive those
are some of my most
likely people what do they do for you so
what they do is like
if somebody wants to upgrade so we have
the private group obviously which if you
join the private group you get all the
curriculum you get discord access you
get access to our forum access to me
but these gentlemen are if you want
one-on-one
coaching experience so you want somebody
actually getting on a call with you
that is exactly where you're trying to
get like in life you know
multi-millionaire status they can walk
you through everything which some people
like that experience like they really
value that
me i can learn from a course like you
just give me a course i'll learn
but i understand there's a segment of
the population that would much rather
have
you personally teach them something
rather than you in a course form just
teach them so you pay them
to coach your people yup
yup anybody that upgrades to those
packages they pay you and then you pay
the
coach how does that yeah yeah if a
client comes in
they want one-on-one coaching from
somebody you know like one of those guys
that's had tremendous amount of success
then
um you know they pay for the program
essentially and then i i pay the coaches
so but i pay the coaches like a set
amount and they're like some of the most
like important people um so yeah what
are the chances someone goes around your
back they go to the coach saying
hey let's cut out jeremy let's just do
something on this i thought about that i
think about all these things all the
time
it's possible somebody could try to do
that but these coaches uh you know
i mean i don't think they would do that
to me you know they're like really good
guys they
they you know i mean they have so
they're already so successful that it's
like it doesn't even make sense for them
to try to
go behind my back and create a bunch of
drama and and put a bad name and
reputation out there and ruin a
relationship or something like that but
i have thought about that before i'm
like i could picture somebody trying to
go
around it or something like that um yeah
but yeah that would just
be messy you know so that wouldn't be
good for anybody
but uh yeah i mean it you know the
payrolls the payroll's no job that's
a hundred thousand so you gotta be
making many multiples of that
yeah yep yeah i would say so
i mean you know between youtube and
everything else yeah definitely
um and then never mind that like the
stock accounts keep getting bigger and
bigger and bigger
um so when i make a profit you know it's
bigger and bigger the dividends are
bigger and bigger so do you
do you worry if the market goes down
let's just say over the next
few years it's just every year goes down
10 10
10 like multiple years in a row do you
how do you think that would impact your
business
well it's interesting because we
actually do better in a
what i found is we do quite a bit better
in a downtrending market that's going
down which is opposite what i thought
but a lot of people um
want to buy in when the market's dipping
and so a lot of people have the
mentality that i'm not gonna
you know like if you if you're buying in
the group it's because you think you're
gonna take stock park investing super
serious
and if you think you're gonna take that
and you might make that investment
yourself and
you know learn all that stuff it's
because you believe you're going to
make a lot of money right and a lot of
people are trained because they watch
your videos my videos
everybody's videos and they know buy the
dip buy the dip
buy the dip it's something that's put
out there all the time so a lot of
people
actually um when the market's going up
like crazy they're like ah
no i'll stay away from that let me know
when the next time the market dips and
then i'm gonna get involved
my concern would be so far i'd say since
2010
the dips that we've seen have not lasted
longer than a few months
so a few months a lot of people will
come and buy in and then it goes back
up and that reinforces by the dip by the
dip by the dip
i'm concerned what would happen if
consistently we go through four or five
years where every year is negative and
people buy the dip
and then it drops another eight percent
they buy the dip and then it drops
another five percent they buy the dip
ten percent many years of that and they
just get to a point where they're like
you know what
why am i going to keep investing i keep
losing year after year after year
yeah this might not be for me i could
see that if
kind of two scenarios played out like
one the government stops all sorts of
stimulus and doesn't do any stimulus in
the future and interest rates go up
i could see that and if there aren't any
special companies like if the united
states we just stopped producing special
companies
i could see that it's a special
companies where you really get the
insane
gains in the market it's the tesla it's
the google it's the apple it's the
amazon
it's the amd it's nvidia so if we get in
a scenario
where there's just no good stocks
because all the companies are crap
then yeah that could definitely happen
but for
my the way i teach people it's
individual stocks so it's all about
finding
the great opportunity so whether we're
in a market that stagnates goes down
there's still going to be stocks that
way outperform and it's just about
finding those stocks that's a beautiful
thing
if you're buying an index fund that's a
whole different story though
what do you think of the stimulus do you
think i don't know if we want to talk
about you know you should talk
to you should be a stimulus it's
tough man i mean this is the this is the
edgiest yeah we've been
yeah i think there should be stimulus so
i mean part of me sees the overall
economy as doing fairly decent
you know we were out you know down there
santa monica last night and
it was you know it was a lot of business
going on there was a lot of commerce
um but i don't think we're getting a
full picture because people have such
limited ways of spending money
and so i'm wondering you know when we go
to some of these places and let's say
it's busy
[Music]
maybe it's just because people have so
much less to spend money on
because you know think about it you want
to go to a concert
you can't do that right now your friends
are closed gyms are closed you want to
go
to the uh rams game can't do that think
about the
massive amount of just events and things
like that that are just completely shut
down right now
the convention business the meeting up
in person
um i mean when you start adding up we
probably do need another stimulus
package i'll be honest um
and and then we really need the country
to open up more and more in 21
i think otherwise we can get into some
trouble you think it's warm in here
it's not too bad i'm not like oh i'm
dying hoodie
yeah i'm fine why are you hot it's warm
in here really i don't think it's warm
in here at all we got a nice breeze
this is the same argument you guys had
when kevin was here yeah i wanted to see
another
another person thought it was warm in
here yeah and so you know
what do you think graham do you think
there should be no stimulus so what are
you thinking i don't know man i
i think part of me just hates relying on
the government for anything
and just expecting that they're going to
help us out i don't think is that is a
healthy mindset to have
because it could be i mean because then
you're really relying on someone else
to i think it's so much better to take
things into your own hands initially i
mean if you get something great
but if not i i wouldn't rely on that
and i also think that some businesses
especially the ones that get these huge
bailouts
um i i i don't think that we should like
teach them a lesson
but i think some of those big businesses
yeah
that get these enormous bailouts
why why are we supporting some of those
business not all of them i think some of
them are good
yeah but um and also i think just a lot
of reckless spending
overall yeah that um that should be cut
down
i i can understand that point of view
but i think on the other
you know if you want to go to the other
side there's also this whole like
way of viewing it where imagine you have
you know the local bar or club you know
in santa monica or even restaurant
and they're telling you you have to be
shut down or right
you are forced to be only at 50 bucks
i'm talking about some of these
huge but like i get like airlines
yes now i get why they did did it for
the airlines
because they employ so many people so by
bailing them out they've inadvertently
bailed everyone else out as well
i'm not the small bit like i think if
the government forces you to shut down
they should compensate you for that i
think that's
that's that's something that that should
be done yeah
um but i think the way it was done was
such a mess
but it was and it was rushed yeah the
whole thing was rushed
but uh could have absolutely i think
have been done better
i i worry about uh stock if you want to
talk about what i worry about with stock
prices i worry about it you know another
stimulus and the stock price is shooting
up a ton more
probably you know yeah i mean why would
you worry about the stock prices because
i mean
a lot of these companies already have
really rich valuations i mean there's
some definitely good deals on the market
but there are a lot of companies
especially a lot of these big ones that
already have you know these really high
valuations
and if we put if if you just print
another two trillion dollars just put it
out there
um a lot of that's going to end up in
assets again and i think real estate's
probably going to keep going up and
stocks will probably keep going up
as well especially when you talk about
the low interest rate environment we're
in
um so yeah it's it's a it's a tough
you know whole situation because you
know there's definitely people out there
businesses that need the stimulus
because they're being forced to be shut
down or they literally just can't
operate the same
um but at the same time a lot of that
money just somehow ends up in uh
you know the tops pockets and then the
top puts it in stocks and real estate
yep
so and then your dollars are devalued so
you know
that money you got in your savings
account is just you know being worthless
i just think we're gonna have to pay for
it in something else you might get some
money now up front
but you're gonna pay it back through
higher prices elsewhere you're just
going to do it slowly
yeah what is it what do they call it
death death by a thousand yeah
thousand putts yeah that was it uh yeah
that's what i think it's
that's what i think it's gonna be you
might you might get
your money now but okay with the price
of
a loaf of bread now is a dollar more
price of
going out is a little bit more your
dollar buys you a little bit less stocks
are a little bit more
yeah it's a whole bunch of things that
just you end up paying for it
it's true yeah which which makes your
dollars worth less and less
right i do agree i've always thought
like considering the current climate of
everything like with everything going on
with the stimulus and everything being
shut down
there's no way that we're not gonna pay
for this in the future because we really
haven't i mean the dip
realistically it didn't last very long
whatsoever and we've recovered and
then some yeah you know there's no way
that we're not going to suffer any
ramifications whatsoever frankly i think
it's going to be
i think it's going to be taxes i think
all that all the tax rates are going to
go up
but who wants to be the one to push that
that's that's the thing
because you also if you tell everybody
you're going to raise a tax
on everybody and not just the richness
everybody all of a sudden people start
saying i don't know if i'm going to vote
for you
so i don't know if you just say you're
going to rich taxa rich people are like
okay that's fine
you know some people are okay as long as
it's not me but if you're talking about
a blanket tax increase across the board
a lot of people you know
regardless of what side of the aisle
you're honest and start saying hmm
well you don't you don't just raise the
tax rate you raise other little things
as well so that the net
turns out to be it's maybe you don't
raise the federal income tax but you
just
you tax the medicare a little bit more
social security an extra one percent
yeah you add in a little few extra
things you get rid of a few deductions
or you complicate things in some way
that people don't fully understand well
they're considering raising the
california's
uh state income tax highest tax bracket
to like 16.3 yeah that didn't pass
oh it didn't pass thankfully no oh gosh
no no
thankfully thankfully so it's over
that's it for now
for now it does not mean it cannot be
reintroduced next year which i think is
probably going to happen
they're going to keep trying yeah um but
yeah the wealth tax also did not pass
that would have been a
whole mess in and of itself that's
impossible to pull off
i can't see them ever being a
well-touched like how do you do that
it's just too messy
yeah you're going to force everybody to
sell assets constantly and it's just
going to create
you can't do it so um and if you do well
tax
people with money are moving i could see
them getting rid of the
the capital gains tax rates for
certain people i could see them taxing
that at ordinary income
i could see them also throwing in an
investment taxes think about it
if you invest your money that is means
you have now
almost discretionary income and uh
that is not an essential expense to
invest not necessarily
i could see them throwing on a little
tax on that that's a lot of many ideas
i know but that that is a luxury to have
the money left over to invest
i could see that because they could be
looking at it as if you should go spend
that
thousand dollars on a flat screen tv
that a bunch of people are going to make
money off of rather than invest that
money and it produces no jobs because if
i if i put my money
in a stock it's not really producing any
jobs if i buy apple stock it's not
helping any jobs if i go buy
you know ten thousand dollars worth of
you know iphones all of a sudden a lot
of companies
you know benefit from that a lot of
workers benefit from that whether it's
here
in china like imagine that like a one
like a half a percent investment tax
imagine that i do i do think though that
like investing in big companies
uh definitely helps the company though
like giving them funding to continue
their operations
like although it's like it's like
picking up a piece of trash
it doesn't seem like a big deal in the
greater scheme of things just picking up
a little piece of trash on the ground
but if everyone were to do it it
definitely makes a difference it's like
but there's something called the
velocity of
money yeah and it's in its what value
your dollar has so if you take
a 20 bill and you spend it that
20 has a velocity of a five so for every
one dollar you spend it gets
recirculated
five times like you spend it at the
restaurant they pay their worker with
that the worker then goes and pays
groceries at that
that then goes to the grocery store
owner who then pays their rent with that
so it goes it circulates five times
when you invest your money it has a
velocity of like
one and a half to two so for every
twenty 20 you invest
it's only getting circulated one or two
times versus five times and you spend it
so they look at how much money is
circulating throughout the economy and
they see
that as what they've what they view as
uh the health
that's what that's what scared me in
march and april because we've never shut
off velocity of money like that and also
just i mean not completely shot off
velocity money but
in a way we've never done before that's
what freaked me out i'm like how do you
get that back up and running and things
like that but
i think you know having all the stimulus
out there i would like to see
is them giving tax deductions
for spending your money i think here's
the thing
i think they need to make it so
appealing for you to spend your money
that you decide to spend it instead of
invest it
if they literally say that the average
person can begin
deducting their expenses they take their
standard deduction of twelve
thousand dollars a year but then on top
of that they could deduct the money that
they spent
up to two thousand dollars a year on
restaurants up to two thousand dollars a
year
in discretionary spending imagine that's
an interesting idea people would love to
do that and here's the thing too even if
they're in a low tax bracket
if they don't fully understand we're
talking about the average person a lot
of people don't understand how that
works
and they're just like oh it's a tax
deduction they don't know that them
spending a dollar is only gonna
save them 10 cents on that dollar yeah
but wouldn't it also help like it would
hurt those who
like are on the borderline of investing
like the lower income people that think
about it but don't really invest
and then you say you can just put your
money elsewhere and then maybe
maybe but in theory if you're spending
your money that much
that is going to help with the
businesses which would then need to hire
more people
to then keep up with that demand because
now imagine people spend 10
more everyone spends 10 more yeah
incentives are huge man i mean that
could i
you know i agree more people would spend
a lot more money i mean you think about
like
think about it in context of like why do
i not just keep all my money
in a savings account because i'm
incentivized to put my money in stocks
real estate stocks real estate go up
i have money in a savings account it
becomes worth less and less and less
over time
and so i'm like i don't want my dollars
put in stocks buy real estate
and so i agree if you're incentivized to
do something just as a human like you're
going to do whatever is the best play
for you and if that's spending money
you're going to do it
i think that i think that would uh that
would help if any politicians are
watching this right now
seriously offer a tax deduction for
average people
anybody can take it that reduces their
taxable income from money they spent
on um non-essentials
interesting just entertainment food
travel cars what else what else would
you spend money stuff like that
yeah you know give it to a little bit
for the stock market
i think there should be i know we have
401ks but just allow people
in a taxable account to take some sort
of upfront deduction
something small they could write off 25
percent of what they invest something
like that i think would would help
imagine if they took it one step further
and they were like
if you buy from um let's say furniture
manufacturers
that make furniture in the usa versus
overseas
wow then all of a sudden you know all
those industries start to boom and
unmask
what they what they would end up doing
i'll tell you what they'll instead of
doing that they'll put a tax
on everything else not manufacturing
that's what they want
that's what they would do they're like
you got to pay a 10 tax on imported
goods but if you buy it here
you know do that i don't know something
something like that but anyway i agree
i think that would be fantastic yeah
they should they should do they should
be doing that yeah anything that's
manufacturing i run for office graham
everyone wants i mean
what do you think about you know since
you're a california resident like what
do you think about
you know the california tax rates the
state tax rates
ridiculous man is it honestly i i've
started looking in because i've never
paid attention to the california attack
ever in my entire life until about three
years ago
okay start paying attention the amount
of money that california wastes
is just insane it's so stupid
just the frivolous spending and i don't
get it we should
california should in terms of the tax
revenue
be one of the most luxurious state like
the like the
most prosperous state to live in you
would think that that outside would be
like
gold sidewalks and just
flowers ever like if you look at beverly
hills
um their city is run so meticulously
and then you look at other cities that
are just
i don't know where the money goes and i
think i think it's just these these
outdated models and and just the
legislation
and the hoops everyone has to jump
through that by the time you get
anything done
it costs 10 times more yeah
jack and i watched this video the other
week about the two million dollar
bathroom
and it was it was it showed this
bathroom that was two million dollars to
manufacture
and they say how does this cost two
million dollars we built this other
thing privately
for what was it a hundred thousand
hundred and fifty thousand dollars
privately that's substantially better
quality
but this bathroom built publicly cost
two million how does that happen well i
feel like
there's money going behind like i don't
want to say there's like these handshake
deals of like hey we'll employ you
if you do this uh look at the government
contracts yes government contracts it
should because
i i feel like and maybe i'm not educated
enough on this to to know what i'm
talking about but my understanding is
that sometimes they have minimums they
have to spend
to show that they're spending the money
so they suspend it anyway they don't
they don't look they're not like if a
person says
like i'm gonna spend my hard-earned
money on this i'm going to negotiate
that i'm going to get the price down i'm
going to cut costs and try to get the
best value
but when you're a government doing this
it's like let's get it done
how much is that okay fine whatever you
just pay whatever
so i think what what i would love to do
or like
have done is for someone to really go
through the state's budget
and figure out what's working what's not
working where are we spending money
and where is it going and figure out
what can we cut back on
where are we overspending and we should
have a surplus every i mean
really you would think that we should
have such a big surplus but now we're at
a deficit
where does it go two million dollar
bathroom yeah
but but not only that but the but the
homeless problem has been
worsening it and it's it's gotten so bad
yeah in the last i would say the last
two years
and uh i i think just the state isn't
providing
the assistance and the mental health
facilities that should
be out there yeah we also have a slowing
growth rate so this past year we had the
lowest growth weight
rate that we've ever had since like
1900.
wow yeah it's gonna be what if it's what
if it was to go negative that's the
that's a big question
it's gonna start going everything yeah
this this last year had a net
uh migration loss negative oh so it was
or it's already
gone last year was negative in terms of
uh migration in
to the uh into los angeles county okay
but los
can los angeles county birth rates
increased to the point where we're still
growing
but the migration into los angeles
decreased for the first time
wow but it makes sense housing is so
expensive
state tax rate is so expensive uh the
whole city i think is deteriorating i've
never said that like i grew up here yeah
30 years right yeah and i would say the
last
three to four years have just it's gone
worse and worse and worse
and then maybe what do you think this
whole pandemic is kind of like the the
knife
you know finishing off putting in the
coffin yeah i think it was already going
downhill
okay um and i think when people realize
that they could work remotely
i think a lot of people are like you
know what i'm gonna leave wow
i think the state has potential to to
return back but if they
really got to just get down on that
where this money comes from because
what they're doing now is like okay we
don't have enough money let's jack up
the tax rates but meanwhile
that's driving people out nothing is
getting better they're going to tax
people more they're going to have more
to spend
but they're still going to have the same
problem it's just overspending yeah it's
lifestyle inflation on a state level
it's like someone making 60 grand live
in paycheck to paycheck then you're like
all i need is 80 grand give them 80.
somehow they still living paycheck to
paycheck
where does the money go the state i
think is doing the same thing and it's
really sad to see
yeah i was covering that on my channel
recently in like
san francisco like they're talking about
tents everywhere man yeah
and you know you come out of your place
there's needles on the ground there's
feces on the ground like you you know
and you live in
yeah it's like it's yeah it's it's the
same way you expect it to be so bad i
started spending more time here i mean
it's gnarly yeah it's
insane you have a venice beach where you
have these
two to ten million dollar houses
and ten feet away or sometimes in front
of these houses
are tents there are people living in
tents
in front of a 10 million house what the
heck
seriously and it's it's it you don't
believe it until you see it yeah that
but there's not only this this big
wealth gap but
the state does not have the resources or
the facilities
to assist these people and give them the
proper care they need because that's
really what it's about it's not about
get the homeless people out from my
house not in my backyard it's not about
it's about making sure the resources are
properly funded to take care of these
people properly
because right now they don't exist i
don't know where the money is going
yeah that's crazy not only that yeah
also crime rates have been increasing
dramatically yes but also but but
what what's increased lately is that
they're not i my understanding
is that they're taking former uh like
felon charges
and calling them misdemeanors because
jails were being overcrowded with
petty crimes so crime under a thousand
dollars that would include
um uh narcotics uh small
theft stuff like this wow and previously
those people would go to jail but jails
were getting overcrowded it was too
expensive to fund the jails with all
these people
um so they said we're those are gonna be
misdemeanors and we're just going to
almost
stop enforcing those wow and as of
recently they've been letting people out
and also just not arresting people
for little misdemeanors and stuff like
that or maybe even more serious crimes
because of the illness as well so
they've been really cautious about that
so
since we've started experiencing the
illness there's also been a dramatic
spike since then right and it makes
sense like initially when you see that
on the ballot
it's like why would you put someone in
jail let's just say that's going to cost
60 000 a year to put someone in jail
for a crime that was let's say 400 bucks
why would you the numbers don't make it
so on the surface people say okay fine
but what what ends up happening is that
that those crimes become a lot more
prevalent because they're not enforced
and those people don't get necessarily
the resources that they would have
to lead themselves to turn their lives
around
like i was reading stories online of um
uh
drug usage of that that whole thing yeah
and some people were saying listen i was
that person who and it just doesn't
apply to everybody yeah but somebody was
saying i was that person
i was buying drugs i was on this path
going to jail was the best thing that
happened to me because it forced me to
confront
that and enter into sobriety yeah and
they're saying if if i never went to
jail i
i would have continued down that path i
could see that and i think a lot of it
is mental health related and
uh i think in the 70s is my
understanding a lot of those facilities
were shut down
um i don't i don't know the reason i
don't know i don't know how much this
costs but it's just something needs to
be done it's not getting done
uh throwing more money at the problem is
not going to help i think the whole
thing needs to be rebuilt from the
ground up
yeah i mean you know driving over here
there's a guy like was walking down the
street here and
and he's like and he's walking barefoot
on the ground
yeah it's just like he's like out of his
mind is i don't know if he was on
something or just has like mental issues
but yeah like that person
you know i you know yeah that was the
stat that i looked i think it was 65
of homeless or mentally ill in los
angeles i read up a study on this
um i think another it's like 15 or 20
percent
uh narcotics and i think there's a small
portion of those people
that are truly that are down on their
luck but those people
are typically transient and that they're
they're homeless for a short period of
time
okay before they can get themselves back
up and running i just don't think the
social services are good enough
to help the people who really need help
yeah all right
it's crazy though everywhere you go you
see people like that everywhere you go
my first week here i was driving to
ralph's and i saw
a homeless person walking on a crosswalk
screaming at a palm frond
pointing and screaming at a palm frond
making a huge scene
i saw a homeless person walking downtown
and there was an old lady eating
at like a restaurant with her family and
this homeless person's running
uh like back and forth on the street
stopping cars
and he walks over to this lady puts his
head this close to her and just
yells like nothing sensible just into
her ear
and this is also during times where we
have the illness yeah and this person is
like
invading her personal space yelling in
her ear it's just well that's
that's the thing is that now families
are feeling like they're not
uh they're not safe here yeah well you
get a lot of families yeah who what is
that that that lady's probably not going
to go out again
no way she's like you know she's going
to be terrified yeah she's like i'm not
gonna
that was hard to see and also like
mornings now i sometimes go surfing once
or twice a week
and when i go surfing on the beach
homeless people are just like
everywhere just sleeping on the sand as
well
yeah it's gotten really bad and um
what i've been hearing as well is that
again i don't have any definitive proof
of this but my understanding is that
other states will
take their homeless people here to
california
and to los angeles that that's been my
understanding from what
right i don't know what other cities and
states you're talking about
you mentioned to me you may and i did
some research on this and i was curious
that you told me
las vegas offers their homeless
population a one-way ticket to anywhere
they want
and a lot of it ends up in we do that
california
but uh i i was researching this a lot of
other states do that as well
oh wow yeah and and it is a thing so
i'm not the most educated on this so i
don't think any of us are yeah so i
don't want people to
take it to los angeles yeah so i don't
want people to take this
like for fact right do your own research
understand
just talking about my experiences from
my limited
yeah it's but it's it's gotten a problem
regardless it has changed dramatically
i've lived in here my entire life
in the last three years i would say the
last 12 months have been the most
transformative i've never seen it so bad
before
ever but why do you think they're all
coming to los angeles if we have
such bad programs and assistance i think
i think it's
enforcement i think it's because there's
very yeah there's no enforcement
good weather um yeah which is very
important
and also safety in numbers you're less
likely to be singled out
if you're in a group of thousands of
other people there are communities
like you walk and there will be hundreds
of tents lined up
and they're playing music they're like
having fun yeah like
no absolutely if if i were homeless i
would rather be in a group
of other people like that it makes sense
that yeah and not on my own
somewhere with bad weather so it makes
sense why they would come here i get it
but it is
just sad because people shouldn't like
have to live like that right
they should have programs we should have
some kind of funding or at least
redirect funding for coming up
who knows elsewhere right and you would
think for
the tax rates that all of us pay that
there would
that some of that would be going towards
funding programs to help
people like that and it's not i don't
know where it's going
geez that's intense man yeah yeah i
don't know where it's going either
that's it's a whole sketchy situation
because it's not like the highways are
perfect and the roads are all perfect so
it's not like you can say well yeah the
construction's perfect here and our
infrastructure is amazing so
it's yeah let's talk let's talk about a
little bit more about taxes i have a
question for
jeremy yeah did you watch the video that
graham did with kevin o'leary
uh i did yeah okay so kevin said
that one of the biggest mistakes that
you can do is not sell
to realize gains when you think a
company could be
overvalued or 100 discrete disagree i
mean there's a lot of things
most of that video i disagreed with him
on kevin o'leary you know i just have a
different point of view no you don't
i mean when you own great assets truly
great assets you don't sell them
unless things have changed or you need
the money to put in better let me
let me clarify this i said to kevin
kevin
said why didn't you sell some of these
and then rediversify and i said i don't
want to pay taxes because 50
of that is going to go to tax so i may
as well instead of selling a stock for
200 and paying half of that it's the
same thing as me buying
waiting for the stock to go down to 100
i'd rather just not sell so you're
saying
you would rather not sell to not get
that money taxed
up front not even for tax it's just like
where am i if i have somewhere
truly better put the money an asset
that's better put the money i'll put it
there
but why do i want to move that money to
cash okay let's just say i sell an asset
a stock of mine
if the money goes to cash is that money
better served in cash or that assets
that's a great asset right if it's a
truly great asset
it's way better over there than in cash
cash is just like we talked about it's
just going to be devalued more and more
over time they're going to keep print
like this isn't ending like the
the stimulus packages of the world will
get bigger and bigger and bigger as time
goes on
i mean nowadays we're talking about two
trillion dollar stimulus package
you go about 30 years ago you couldn't
even fathom that so imagine where we're
going to be at 30 where it's going to be
like a 20 trillion dollar
package and we're like oh that's just
normal you know it's just it is what it
is so
unless you have somewhere better to put
the money why not keep the money there
let's say you own a real estate
investment property
right and it throws you off it's a great
asset it usually appreciates right
and it throws you off some rental income
and things like that why would you get
rid of it
unless unless you truly had a better
property put the money in you had no
cash
so you you didn't believe in it it seems
like you actually at the
at its core you kind of agree with kevin
o'leary it's like
don't consider taxes when investing just
kind of consider
putting your money into good solid
companies that you believe in
yeah let's say tesla goes from 400 to
700
why did that camera die again let's say
it goes from 400 to 700
um you wouldn't sell at a point where
you felt like tesla's overvalued
well you could make an argument that
tesla's overvalued today right and i'm
not selling but let's say it went to 400
to a thousand
let's just say tomorrow because of a
tweet from elon musk that you knew
probably is not sustainable yeah maybe
then
maybe i mean that would be so insane
because then you're talking about
a 400 you know less than a 400 billion
dollar mark cap into
you know was that one trillion then i
might have to actually consider at that
point because that would be so insane
but i mean as long as it's somewhat you
know
uh believable like like i test without
1164p very high
but you can def i can see a way how
tesla grows into that over the next five
years
if tesla's at a 300 ford p i don't know
it might be harder
or a thousand or something but in
selling oh my god ramsay
what happened oh what the heck
he's way up there so in selling
the tesla stock at one thousand dollars
you wouldn't even think about taxes so
that's what i that's the point i'm
trying to get at is that kevin
would not think about taxes when selling
or when
doing something yeah i will say i do try
to make my decisions based upon
fundamental decisions other than taxes
taxes i mean i'll consider
everything and you know when i go into a
decision like that but that's like
the last thing i'm considering
essentially taxes is at the end
i'm considering first to have somewhere
better put the money is that really a
smart decision
things like that and then and then we
can worry about
you know taxes at the very end of the
process what do you think of taxes
what do i think of taxes so i mean i'm
thrilled with taxes i think i pay a way
lower rate than i should uh i'm amazed
at the whole
tax system uh you know it really opened
up my eyes when i actually got like a
a tax you know put like a professional
tax count a few years ago
i remember you know people around me
especially my dad he was like oh you
know once i started making you know
uh you know really good money he's like
you need to have a professional do this
like you need to stop doing it yourself
on hdr block or whatever
and he's like whatever you you pay them
you're going to get one of the highest
rois you'll get paying anybody
and i figured that out like i think the
first year i used uh
a professional tax person i think was
2017 17 or 18.
and i can tell you like that very first
year i was like what there's all these
deductions of this and that
there was things i wasn't even doing
before that i even know you could do
and then we got the tax cuts the next
year i think was 18 right the new tax
cuts went into the law is the 18
tax cuts and jobs act yes that's what it
was and then
like yeah you know so yeah it's amazing
man i think uh
you know and obviously i live in las
vegas which is no state income taxes
so you know i i i'm definitely because
you think about it right i mean imagine
let's say you make a million dollars a
year
and you have to pay you know let's say
five percent of that to a state every
year right
so you have 50 000 less every year
versus a state like like i live in where
you have to pay no state income taxes
you know that 50 000
over a 10-year span it's a half a
million but it's a lot more when it's
invested and you
if you can get just an eight percent
return which is very average i'm
definitely able to get a lot better than
like eight percent return never mind if
you amp your
your gains up to let's say 20 a year on
average then imagine if it's 30
and if you can do that consistently for
a decade or two
i mean you're talking about a difference
of millions if not tens of millions of
dollars
so that's that's where um i think
that's where you really have to start
considering taxes i feel like the more
money you get
the more you have to start considering
taxes and figuring out man am i really
making the best life decision by living
in a place like you know that maybe
takes a lot of your money so yeah it's
it's
it's really key in the whole thing and i
cannot i can understand why some people
even move out of the country you know i
don't know if i would ever go that way
puerto rico
yeah the thing the thing that the united
states is smart
if you move out of the country and you
want to not pay federal taxes you have
to revoke your u.s
citizenship so
if you if you move out of country you
still have to pay
taxes unless you revoke being a united
states citizen
i think that's where they're intelligent
otherwise i think a lot more people
would do it yeah
there have been stories of i've read
online of people who revoke their
citizenship and then spend less than 90
days
in every country they travel to and they
just pay zero tax
they found some loophole i forget what
it was called
what was it like the flag it was like
flag theory i forget it was like the
five flag theory
something like where they would travel
to different locations for
no more than 90 days at a time and pay
no tax
yeah you can move to monaco pay no tax
you know i think dubai i think dubai
also right
yeah uh is it cayman islands wow i
didn't know that
yeah i i know like i'm pretty sure
monaco dubai
monaco real estate's insane i've
actually looked into it before because i
was like
you know like this is many years ago i
was like what if i get to a point where
i got
20 million dollars in stocks 50 million
dollars in stocks which was like five
six years ago i was looking into this
and
i was thinking about it and i was like
imagine you make 10 million dollars in
stocks and you have to pay
you know whatever amount to the
government let's say you take 10 million
dollars in profits
and i was like man imagine a monaco you
paid nothing
you could still do all the same trades
you know what i mean like you can do all
your research all you need is an
internet what are your time investing
what are you talking about kevin about
let's see if there's 10 million dollars
in stocks
and our last podcast we talked about all
you need to do is get a loan against
your stocks and just spend the loan
then you'll never have to sell your
stocks
yeah yeah so i i looked for i didn't
look further into it but i was talking
to my friend about that and this is
something that confused me a little bit
so if you take a loan
against your stock portfolio how would
you pay
back the loan without realizing the
gains
of selling off the the could be
dividends but
keep in mind you also let's say you you
have 10 million dollars in the stock
market you take out a 2 million
loan now you got 2 million cash you
could use some of that cash to
continually pay back the loans your only
net cost really there is just interest
yeah they charge you the interest but
then you're still gonna have to like i
mean you don't just take out two million
dollars to put two million dollars back
into it
yes you do because you're paying less in
interest than you are in taxes so let's
say the interest is five percent
but your tax rate would be twenty
percent it makes sense to pay five
percent in
interest on that portfolio than twenty
percent in tax so you take out let's say
two million
and then you invest like a million of
that two million and then with that
money
you're no you or you could have cash or
let's say you could go and buy a house
and the stocks produce dividends there's
a lot of ways you could pay that off
but also if you're taking dividends and
stuff from the portfolio that you draw
from
don't you have to pay capital gains on
that which is essentially the same thing
right
but it allows you access to a lot of
money without selling
that's true that's true that's true i
don't personally do it but i could
understand some people wouldn't do that
i i stay away from margin nowadays
because i just i you know the temptation
is really hard when
you start going on margin and then you
see your stocks dip or other stocks dip
it's really
tempting to just say oh just do it it's
not necessarily margin
it's called the pledge to asset line you
could do that too yeah so pledge to
asset line they'll usually give you like
20 to 50 percent of your portfolio back
as a low interest rate loan fixed for a
certain time frame
and um it depends on the stock like
certain etfs and bonds
they'll give you up to like 80 value
other stocks they'll give you like 10
15 depends what it is but uh it looks
really interesting charles schwab has
something where
if you have more than two and a half
million dollars invested with them you
could take out a loan
it's under two percent it's like one
point seven five percent
uh for i think it's like a year to it's
some absurdly low rate that you can get
on stocks yeah in margins
well you know i know we're talking about
kind of two different subjects but in
relation to margin it's crazy because i
always thought
the most you can take out is 2x at my
peak craziness of
2015 with margin i was over 2x margin
which was i i didn't even realize you
could go that that far
with margin actually so you know it's
just completely dumb to do that because
you you open yourself up to margin calls
and things what brokerage do you use
uh fidelity fidelity yeah i've been
using them for about 12 years
do you have any other brokerage accounts
i i i have a robin hood which i
hardly ever use uh i just set it up so i
like understand how to use it because
some people ask me questions sometimes
what about weeble
no no we do i do use chase uh i've been
trying out their product
um jp morgan very okay
it's very it's it it's a worse
experience of fidelity or anything else
i really tried so i
you know but it's still new yeah it's
still new and
i think they just did it because you
know it's just competitive
exactly you know stay relevant in
different spaces everybody wants to be
everything now all these banks are
trying to be
in everything man they want to be your
brokerage they want to do this they want
to do that that's where the money is
though
you have to lead in with something free
they could charge you
elsewhere like robin hood i could see
getting into banking
i could see them having their own credit
card being a one-stop shop for
everything
and then now the banks are trying to do
the same thing they're trying to be
robin hood
trying to be the banks yeah let's talk
about my favorite thing
and graham's least favorite oh options
trading
oh let's let's what do you
what do you think about it and so and
what did you think because there were
there was mixed feedback i would say
70 i would say about 80 of people agreed
with me when i told kevin
that he should sell covered calls on
tesla okay what do you think oh
really quick i call it picking up
pennies that's the term picking him
pennies
other people calling people you heard it
and you do like jack what do you think
about this
like i was like that's not true i was
like i'm gonna teach jack a thing or two
no i've never
of course i've heard of that but it's
not true at all well let's hear we got
the
expert here i mean i so the real option
is first let me just say
one person's picking up the pennies and
the other person's the steamroller
okay right yeah but eventually
yeah i i don't i don't sell covered
calls i can understand why other people
do and i know people that do it and do
it really successfully
uh it's just not something because my
thing is i'm in stocks
for massive gains like i'm not just in
stock for that eight percent per year
yeah um to yeah no if i'm going to try
to get eight percent per year i'll just
put my money in the index fund and call
it a night and not do all this research
right
i'm trying to get 20 30 plus percent
gains so being that i'm in that position
i don't want to limit my gains just by
doing like let's say covered calls or
something like that because then you're
limiting your upside
so i get that that makes sense for you
right like
because you spend so much time picking
out specific stocks and then you put a
lot of money in these stocks
and you hold right but you find a
desirable price for these stocks that
you're happy to buy them at right yeah
so what if instead of selling covered
calls it seems like it would be more
your style to sell a put
so that's when you receive the premium
but then have at a price that you
already think this is a good price point
i'm happy to buy this stock and you also
get a little bit of money on top of that
selling puts is the strategy that makes
the most sense for me because it's
essentially putting a bottom on a stock
and saying if it goes down to this price
i'm willing to buy that stock and so
yeah i have a friend
of mine who's always like dude why are
you not selling you know you should be
selling puts you should be selling puts
because you
you believe this stock's a great deal at
his price why not make some premium on
that
and then if it goes down a bunch more
you're going to buy it anyways so go
ahead and buy it
so i i do agree um i should be
selling put options i 100 agree it's
just like man this
this there's so little time in the day
like you know
that's the thing it's like there's so
many things i could do in a day
is is selling put options is it
important enough to me
or should i put that time in trying to
find the next pla you know playing 13
the next
test higher like that hire a jack i
might to go and do i might observe i
might literally
manages all of your stuff like do you or
do you
coordinate with all of your people i
have different people that manage
different things for me
but i have thought about adding it's
interesting you brought that up i have
thought about adding someone to my team
that is just looking for other ways i
can make money things like selling put
options and be like okay so here's our
portfolio here's why this makes sense
now
um and actually them being on payroll
not like me outsourcing that to somebody
else like them
them being like my main man um or woman
to like
look into other companies too because
then i was thinking about it one day and
i was like
what if i had somebody that i i
personally train them 100 on what to
look for in stocks and like
it's the thing is it's hard to find
somebody that's going to think exactly
like me and have the experience
and if somebody thinks exactly like me
and they have experience more than
likely they have a lot of money already
yeah yeah and so therefore they might
not even be interested in that so it's a
tough thing but i should
it would be really beneficial to me
especially as my accounts grow bigger
and bigger and bigger
because what if i could make an extra
half million dollars a year selling put
options
that's a half million dollars a year you
know what i mean it's not like it's a
small amount of money and as the numbers
continue to grow and grow and grow
um i think i think i might do that
eventually over time
even buying calls because if you are
so confident in these can i do that
sometimes you buy calls
and do you see them through all the way
till the end or do you ever when the
company appreciates and value you exit
the contract early
call sometimes i'll sell early yeah so
like uh i bought a facebook call
uh shoot that would have been a year or
two ago because i believe facebook was
gonna go up
it went up a bunch and it was a
long-term call so when i buy calls
usually i'm buying for two years
or more that makes sense for you so the
jan 2023's just came out within the past
um three or four weeks now so you're
getting
essentially two years and like three or
four months for that stock to appreciate
over time i'll look at those
opportunities from time to time
especially in october
november and some stocks that i think
are really beating down and have huge
upside potential i might play some
2023 calls in dropbox i might play some
2023 calls in nordstrom stock because
those are two stocks that i think are
likely gonna
appreciate greatly over the next couple
years and it might make sense to buy
some long-term calls in those
but i'm very specific about it like i
don't i don't go super heavy in them
because i hate the feeling of you need
this stock to go to this price by this
date
i love the feeling of just like i can
wait it out if that stock stagnates for
two years who cares maybe the third year
fourth year fifth year
when the stock goes crazy how much do
you invest
uh call options a small amount like
maybe five ten thousand something like
that i never go big it's not like i'm
gonna buy a hundred thousand dollars
worth of calls tomorrow or something
like that it's just
it's too risky for me to do that type of
move um
for my risk tolerance i like taking
risks but i like taking risks that
i have time for it to play out and to
that i mean two years is a good amount
of time but still man it can get
it can get scary like what happens if
the whole economy dips and the whole
stock market goes down a ton
for a year or two we just talked about
that what if the stock market goes down
this year next year
does it go down enough where even if
that stocks if even if that company's
performing great maybe they
can't um get to the other side as far as
the stock price goes so
yeah it's it's a little it's a little
tough but i i do do some options
sometimes
i i teach options um you know in my
private group but mainly just because
i like for people to understand the
downside yeah i think a lot of people
when
when they go into any investment of
especially options they're only looking
at the upside and oh my gosh i can make
so much money
you know and it's like yeah you could
also lose 100 in some of the strategies
depending on which one you do
so um but yeah selling puts man it's
something i should be doing
yeah that i think that is the uh option
i guess like choice yeah that is in most
alignment
with your current trading strategy 100
agree
yeah have you yeah so are you dabbling
more and more into options now
yeah well okay so i don't want to come
off like i'm
definitely not nowhere near like even
considering myself like a
total options trader like i've been
trading for probably four months
jack's coming out with a course soon how
to trade options
more money than i've made in options is
the price you've probably made more
money than most options traders that are
selling courses out there believe me hey
well
i don't know about that but um yeah i've
been i've been doing it for about four
months now
and people were saying like some guy was
like oh you've made 500 or something in
like three months that's abysmal return
and i'm like yeah it is but also at the
same point the reason why
the returns were so bad is because when
i was learning i think if you're
learning something something and you're
a total beginner and you barely even
understand like the the fundamentals of
it
go into it with a conservative mindset
don't like go
all in and try to get like 30 gains or
30 losses right in the beginning
yeah you know like in the beginning of
my options training like yeah my returns
were really bad but as of recently i'm
starting to get much better and better
returns like my last
three or four trades my last one was
like seven percent the one before that
was like 20
the one before that was like 22 percent
what's your best one and worst one
you've had so far
i have yes percentage-wise okay my worst
one was probably
like one percent that i gained okay and
then my best one was probably about like
it was mo it was one of the more recent
ones it was around the 23
what was our strategy around the best
one you had so there were completely
different strategies
um one was a short term sell put that
was the bad one
okay so basically if the stock goes
beneath a certain strike price i'm
forced to buy it
and it was like one week in the future
this was very like in the beginning
where i was like oh
i'll take 15 bucks maybe like 10 putting
up 2 500.
but of course it wasn't gonna hit it
because i chose a really conservative
strike price
overall not my favorite strategy it's
just not worth it for me
because who knows it could plummet you
know with the best
uh returns they're all short strangles
okay so that's just setting two brackets
and if the stock price remains between
these two brackets then i get
premium from selling the call and i get
the premium from selling the put
yeah and then i just choose these
brackets based off of kind of it's
i said a formula but i said that also in
a joking way because you never say like
i have like a formula jack has a winning
formula that he will teach you
yeah my formula specifically yeah this i
came up with it yeah 21 year old he's
been training for four months hedge
funds
against him no it's uh
i just i just basically it's uh repeat
process like 45 day theta
45 days out is when i choose a strike
price 16 is the delta
and then that's that's basically i
choose a iv a stock with iv rank
over like 25 because the premiums will
be higher but also
i think i'm gonna try to close all of my
contracts before the election
because uh the when i got into the
contracts it was about a month ago and
i'm guessing as we get closer to the
election the volatility will go up
and since i since i bought a month ago
it didn't really account for the
volatility of the election i'm guessing
so i'm gonna try to exit the positions
because
in selling options you when you're
holding you want a low
volatility but when you're when you're
entering the yeah you want a high
voltage yeah
just a random tip for people sometimes
like let's say a stock goes down a ton
tomorrow and let's say you want to buy
calls or something usually
wait a day or two after that because the
price i noticed continues to drop a day
or two after even if that stock
stabilizes
or even if it was to go up a little i've
always noticed that it actually
continues to drop like what you'll have
to pay the premium
i don't know why it doesn't reflect
right away like a stock price will
uh it's just like a little tip out there
i've always noticed it doesn't make
anything that's interesting
yeah it's really it's it's weird that
you think that day
it's down seven percent it's going to
reflect that sometimes it actually
continues the price continues to worsen
quite a bit sometimes three to ten
percent i found even if that stock's
stable the next day
really really weird but um no that
that's
that's intriguing like it's been working
dude like i have i've got like
total return like i'm not over 20 now in
like a couple months
i don't play direction so in fact a
stagnant market is probably a good
market for me
like right now we have a crazy market
and graham argued like oh if you just
put the money in the s p 500
i could have gotten way better returns
which is totally true but also the
market's been rallying
yeah you know and i'm not playing any
sort of direction so i would like to
think you know in a market where we're
not going crazy all the time
i would still be able to get good
returns granted yes if the market's
rallying the ivs will be higher
thus driving up the premium same but
still it doesn't
the market doesn't need to be rallying
for me to be using this method and of
course i just want to say i'm just
gathering data at this point yeah i'm
not saying like
i know what i'm like i'm just i'm just
plugging and playing like i'm trying
different strategies
and what's worked so far is what's
worked and i have yet to lose money i
also i just want to say the put that i
bought where graham says
you don't uh you're not realizing the
loss which
is like i was saying this could be the
first time i lose something because i
bought a put which i've never bought an
option before that was the first time
i did it yeah skechers pl it was on
skechers and sketches went down
for one day okay and i i got fifty
dollars profit
oh technically that was my highest
return that was like forty percent
or something no it was like it was like
a week still sounds insane 40
a week yeah i mean usually usually the
suckers and options of the people that
are
buying puts and buying calls for the
most part you know because 90
i believe or so expire worthless
so it's also hard to play direction i
think like it's it's difficult
to be so you're good at it but yeah but
for like a long term
yeah like yeah short term doing like two
weeks
right exactly so i'm doing 45 days out
because in the first 20 days you see a
lot of time decay
yeah so i'm benefiting from the time
decay and then i'll just exit the
contract early
but i it's really difficult to play
directions in the short term
and a lot of people just they're the
hype around options trading especially
now
people are buying all these options like
crazy because walls you see wall street
bets and the communities
and you see tesla right and i think so
many people are
they have so much hype around tesla that
it's driving up the premiums to like
exorbitant prices
because everyone's buying calls there's
such a demand for calls on tesla
that the premiums for those selling the
calls are just so high and i wouldn't
tell anyone
to like go out and just without knowing
anything just start selling calls on
tesla but i told my dad because
oh really he had 75 shares of tesla and
i told him
he should buy 25 more shares and just
start selling calls and we did the math
the only way he would lose money is if
tesla went below
290 dollars in one month or went above
560 in one month and if and if it like
doesn't hit the the call price which was
500
then also he would get um if it didn't
hit that he would get like 2 300 dollars
like that's like
that's like rent on him yeah like a
property you know what i mean
i've seen i've seen another strategy
employed out there this is a really
risky strategy
but what some people would do is like
let's say they have
you know ten thousand dollars they wanna
play with in options
they try to find the ten companies they
think are going to go
up the most over let's say the next two
years so you're playing like you know
long-term option options like two years
out and what you do is you put a
thousand dollars
in the furthest out strike prices in all
of them
now this is a strategy that if none of
them hit that you're going to lose all
10 000 okay
but your hope is at least one
of them hits sometimes your return can
be
over 100 astronomical like imagine if
you
like let's go back a year and time year
and a half ago in time imagine you you
saw that you did that strategy and you
did it with tesla
oh bank on the yeah on the highest you
know the because you can you can
pay such a cheap price for those so and
then if it hits
yeah no you you you make crazy money the
cool thing about that too is
you don't have to ride it out until the
end if you if you hear
news about a company or you lose
confidence in one of those companies
you can accept a loss of 30 you know 30
percent
and then just write that like write it
off or whatever yeah write it off but
use it as a
lowering your yeah i mean for that
strategy i would be tempted to probably
just keep it in
everything until the end um that's
that's because you
pick out those ten stocks and you you're
yeah yeah i kind of guy yeah
and i would hate to like start making
decisions around like
because you're already taking this
massive risk as it is and i would hate
to make
start making trading decisions around
that and trying to time in and out
well maybe i'll get out of this out and
like if you're going to go in with that
crazy of a strategy it's like just keep
it until the end
and hope one if not two of those stocks
hit and if two of those stocks go
way above that top price the the gains
are going to be
way way more than you put in but it's
really rare you just do index
and lock in
what do you think your portfolio could
be at right now
if instead of putting that money and
like investing in the actual like common
share
common stock whatever you call it yeah
if instead of doing that you just bought
out
long-term call options on all of those
stocks where do you think you would be
ah shoot well i mean you can make an
argument that a lot higher than it is
now
but man it's it's so it's so really
theoretical yeah yeah
right but like yeah i mean it would be a
lot higher
there's no doubt because you think about
all the stocks imagine if i
bought all calls and tesla all calls on
facebook skyworks elf
fizzy get dizzy cruisy doozy like all
these stocks millions
yeah like let's say the public account
was only options and i bought only calls
you know it depends on what strike
prices you get them out and things like
that and where do you where do you sell
them at do you hold them till the end
but yeah i mean that account instead of
860k would probably be
five to ten wow so because
there's just so many home run stocks in
there but man
you know it's always about that risk
reward risk yeah huge risk
you know what if the market kept down
trending that account could have been a
zero
you know imagine if this this whole
market come back we've had over the last
six months imagine if it
just kept going down and then imagine
these options were all expiring let's
say in 2021 or let's say january yeah
january 2021 then we're at zero
yeah so it's it's just like you heard
about
was who was it the softbank guy didn't
he just go
crazy on like buying calls or something
like that that's what i knew the market
talked
exactly as soon as i saw saying do that
i was like markets topped
and then the nasdaq right after that
news came out went from like twelve
thousand started going down yeah
like eleven thousand ten thousand he was
on wall street bets for sure oh 100
he's a mod actually was he really i'm
kidding
it's an amazing community oh do you
peruse wall street beds uh yeah for
memes i try to go on at least once a
week
and see the news it's once a week yeah
oh i'm on there every day or your times
a day everyone's gonna be fresh refresh
i start by noon
yeah you gotta look at the attendees
yeah you have trouble focusing on
recording videos because you're on wall
street
yeah it's all the time you're like it's
become a distraction now honestly to
check reddit because i keep thinking
there's gonna be something new on there
but there's never anything new
yeah i'm hoping i'm gonna be the first
to find some breaking news like
something revolutionary that no one else
is gonna see
it's gonna take you two days to get the
news out anyways it's gonna kevin's
gonna make six videos about it
i'll make three i'm able to get some
videos out there the same day oh really
yeah if i come up with the concept by
7am i'm able to get it out the same day
7am
wow but sometimes but sometimes it helps
to beat later on
to a video because i i get the full
picture i get i don't just
just put out the news as it comes but
sometimes able to get some thought
behind it is more develops
yeah and you can throw more opinion
behind it because you thought it through
for hours now right
yeah no that can make sense 100 i don't
know if these cameras are going to shut
off or not um
dude wouldn't it be nice if they just
recorded for an hour straight
do you have any any strategy in the
short term right now or do you never
consider really the short term and you
always think long term
so if i asked you like your strategy
when we last had you on it'd be the
exact same as
this time yeah i i have really no
specific strategy um in the short term
no it's just adding to positions i
really like um
and building those bigger and bigger
right now i'm i'm building like
four i think different positions right
now in the public account that i can
see as being my potential you know
future facebook skyworks and teslas
of that account um because i'm trying to
get that next batch like tesla
facebook skyworks those were kind of
like the 2018
early 2019 and those are just like you
know the the fruits coming to fruition
or whatever you want to say
and now i'm building out those next
beast positions that i think are gonna
thrive over the next two three four five
years
so did you see uh kev meet kevin
posted something on his instagram where
him and his wife
both picked one stock it was like a year
ago and they wanted to see who could
have the best return in one year
she picked apple and he picked tesla oh
so they bolted really good though yeah
they both put in like ten thousand
dollars and they were just like
wow like crazy yeah that was his must
have went to what 70k and hers went
to yeah it was a lot it was a lot 25
maybe
something like that i don't know it was
it was a really interesting post he's
like oh yeah guys i forgot about this
this is a year later
oh the hsa account no that's different
oh
that's different that's kevin literally
finds accounts with a hundred grand in
the music oh he forgot about this
account
yeah 100 that was funny yeah let's say
you have like a million dollars
and you can only choose three stocks
what three stocks
would you pick to put those million
dollars in three stocks today
today oh shoot i'm probably going
dropbox
i'm going planet 13. oh gosh and i'm
going
facebook so i'm playing like if
you had if you told me i got to put the
money in those three stocks so i'm
playing facebook because risk reward
really attractive the chance i lose
money almost non-exists in the next five
years chance i double up my money or
more
very high uh dropbox is
a similar situation with facebook but
with more upside i feel like actually
quite a bit more upside maybe a little
more dangerous than a facebook but a lot
more upside
and then plant 13s that you know i think
yeah it's all about that reward with
that one
so you heard it here folks we will come
back to this
in ten years oh and see it and see how
he did
that would be that would be interesting
let's just do it in 10 years
okay so i think you know i'm not sure if
this is going to get included
in the podcast but i think we got to
break some some massive news here okay
guys
we've been beating around the bush this
entire video i don't know if this is
going to make it in the video okay
it will graham
is going to move next to me
in las vegas you heard it here okay
breaking and yes i bought the house next
door
the house that i'm building so not my
current house i live in building a house
graham's having a house built out there
let's let's
let's talk about this decision let's
talk about uh
what led you to this let's just let's
just let's just get it out there let's
talk about this a lot a lot of things
but when you showed me las vegas i never
thought i would be
able to live there um when you showed
macy and i
las vegas and it was it was you showed
me a part of las vegas that i've never
seen before
you really like that strip club that
much
macy and i just had the time of our
lives
i can't believe it the crazy horse
wow it was nice there's none here
[Laughter]
so we we macy and i we have to go
down there because that's right that's
where i'm going to film my videos now
exactly
is there better content you could
possibly film that a strip club
yes so anyway so yeah so you should macy
and i
uh just a really beautiful part of
summerlin
and uh some really beautiful parts
[Laughter]
had a great time and that's why we have
all of the uh
twenties uh so anyway um no
anyway yeah we went off the strip so we
went to summerlin
showed him summerlin and and also showed
you you've seen a lot of henderson too
i like henderson you gotta go off the
strip essentially everybody comes to the
strip they just see strip life and
they're like that's las vegas and then
you go to the suburbs and also and you
see you know the parks and the the
community and the homes and
yeah and you showed us this this
community up there where you're building
and it was nice enough when i did the
math and i realized that you know what
it makes sense
it makes sense to do this and uh yeah
we're looking forward to it
yeah that's big man that's gonna be
great we're gonna where are we gonna
build pools that go underground so
connect the houses just swim over and
hey what are you cooking over there
graham
it would be fun to have an underground
pool though yeah the one that goes
underneath
the uh the wall to your place to your
backyard yes
you just swim under that would be fun
yeah it's all night time and it's like
dark out and all of a sudden i'm like
swimming underwater and i just like grab
your
looking out to legs your pool and you
just see like jeremy with some goggles
in your room oh gosh hey what are you
guys doing seeing what my next title is
going to be
so we could steal it yeah you want to go
to crazy horse tonight again or not
this is a joke joke so
yeah vegas yeah we only got one camera
we got one camera we got our last leg
everyone if it cuts out we'll just
finish with audio okay
graham any other reasons a lot of
reasons but i'll i'll discuss it on the
main channel
okay and once stay tuned so now you got
a teaser yeah i broke the news for you
guys okay
yeah and let's keep it a secret on this
channel for now no posting on the main
channel about it no making videos
keep it a secret here for now it's our
little inner secret for people who made
it to this point in the video and then
i'll make a video in the next like few
weeks
that would be cool so thank you all so
much for watching and listening
subscribe to jeremy i appreciate it
financial education thank you
do you have any message to the viewers
do you have any message to the viewers
yes
um invest your money
focus on the long term and invest your
money
there you go smash the like button and
smash it oh addison
so with that said you guys thank you so
much for watching really appreciate it
all of our information is down below in
the description uh smash like button
also limited time this offer actually
expires
uh i think a few days after this is
gonna post your last chance to get those
two free stocks on weeble
now they're both worth at minimum eight
dollars they have two free stocks they
did
all the way up to one thousand six
hundred dollars so that offer expires i
think unlike the 15 to like midweek
so you only have a few more days to
claim the two stocks minimum eight
dollars get that down below in the
description
thank you so much for watching and until
next time
gotta get the spray bottle
can i use the restroom it's right by the
bathroom here it's over here
and then just down there
can i use your restroom
[Laughter]
oh man that was epic i didn't even
realize yeah
all the way up there what the heck
that's insane uh
those turned off
[Laughter]
wow
i can't get over that
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
but yeah wall street bets is is great i
absolutely love it and there's a reason
why wall street bets has like one and a
half million members
and and theta gang has like tens of
thousands you know
tens of thousands data gangs the exact
opposite the people that transact with
wall street bets
no one cares about like oh you're
getting like four percent a month
no one cares about that everyone wants
to know about gaining like 500 percent
or losing data gain
takes some money from wall street's best
exactly yeah
the real money's in theta gang it is
yeah i love dating
it's boring it's like incredibly boring
i don't really look at it that much
yeah but theta gang that's where we need
to start marketing blake those are our
people
all right throw in the the the thing
jack they're on the iced coffee hour
animation
oh yeah that's smart always forget to do
it yeah
oh shoot which camera do i look at
there's so many now you don't even need
so if you're talking to anybody it's
that
back camera that's pointed on you that's
true that's on all of us this is on you
and i
once we get rolling with it well for the
start don't we all look at the same
camera no
yeah we'd all look at this one this one
okay cool oh then also we need uh the
intro
yeah i could do the intro okay uh so uh
yeah
go for it yeah
welcome uh i used to space coffee hour
yeah nice coffee
holy smokers to say no jokers
and then we've made sixty two hundred
dollars all right but do the holy
smokers
all right wow well